only on CBS this morning you saw open
the last half-hour she is still here the
main reason she's here is to reveal her
newest highly anticipated book club
selection
so drumroll what is it okay so my new
book club selection is the Sun does
shine how I found life and freedom on
death row by Anthony Rea Hinton and we
are so delighted and honored to have the
author join us here at the table CBS
this morning featured Hinton you may
recall in April at the head of the
opening of the Legacy Museum in
Montgomery Alabama it features his story
he spent listen to this story nearly 30
years on death row for crimes he did not
commit until he was released in 2015
Anthony Rea Hinton we are delighted we
have all read your book we are so
excited that you're joining us at the
table it's really it's an honor to meet
you and I want you to know this I've
known Oprah as you know for a very long
time I have not seen her as excited
about a book as she was since color
purple where you said if I could I would
stand out on the street I said I would
go on Fifth Avenue I put a little book
sign over me and I would hand out these
books of sandwich board I'll be handing
out these books I hope every person who
can hear our voice today that buys this
and that's how you felt about color
purple she wanted everybody to read it
what was it about this book it because
it's a memoir you normally don't pick
memoirs well no but I was at I was
actually doing a story for 60 minutes on
the museum in Montgomery Alabama founded
by Bryan Stevenson yes the lynching
Museum and I was I was actually rumbling
around Brian's office I'm just looking
at his bookshelves because I always like
to see what people are we and I saw this
aunt lying on his desk and I picked it
up and started like oh this is
interesting and then when I left he
handed it to me I said oh that's a book
I saw on your desk I was rumbling
through your desk and I started to read
it and I couldn't put it down
yeah it's a true story of this man's
anguish and the fact that he was
mistreated and misjudged has never
received any college apology for it from
the state of Alabama
and was on death row for 30 years for a
crime he did not commit you were
arrested you were mowing the grass at
your mom's house and even as you're in
the car the white police officer says
you're gonna be convicted first say what
you were charged with first child was
attempted murder for kidnap and first
degree robbery and as we was going
toward the jail they didn't know about a
gun that detect acts mean anything - do
you own a firearm and I said no and he
said do your mother on one I say yes and
I told him what kind and they dropped me
off in Dora police station went back to
my mother house my mother gave them the
gun trying to help me whatever the case
was
and as they had been fired in 25 years
yes take this over yes Oh 30 and when
they picked me back up as we was going
toward to jail I kept asking them why am
I being arrested they never had to
explain to me why I was being arrested
and finally I actually fit the first
time that's officer why you arrested me
and it seemed it set the office off and
he turned around and he said you want to
know why we arresting you and he told
them to charge as I haven't done any of
that he said well let me tell you
something right now I don't care whether
you did it or didn't do it but I'm gonna
make sure you found guilty and I said
for a crime I didn't commit
he said you must have a hearing problem
didn't I just tell you I don't care
mm-hmm cuz he said you're black yeah
well I got five he told me he said
there's five things they're gonna
convict you would you like to know what
they are and I said yes he's a number
one you're black number two a white man
is gonna say you shot it whether you
shot him or not I really don't care he
said number three you're gonna have a
white prosecute number four you're gonna
have a white judge and number five
you're gonna have an all-white jury do
you know what that's spelled and he
looked at me and he repeated the word
conviction conviction conviction
conviction conviction that's how it's
jargon and even as you were convicted in
this sham of the trial
total sham of a trial you prayed for
God's forgiveness for the people that
did this and I thought was what I think
is so amazing about this book is your
grace and
kindness that you then carried out with
with other men in prison and the the one
one of the parts that just struck me and
I just have to is that there's never
been a book club on death row
no the fan you brought books and I
underlined men would do all kinds of
crazy things rather than spend another
night with their own thoughts bring in
the books I thought let every man on the
row have a week away inside a book books
give you put you in the world that you
never thought you could go and I often
would say I don't need to go to
California give me a book that talks
about California and I can put it in my
head and imagine what it looked like him
and I had read a few books on the street
not break it and I felt that something
was missing all of us was there to been
condemned and been sentenced by the
world that we was would be better off
the yeah and so I decided that until
that day come let's live a life of
fullness and let's start it with a book
top and I started there had to go and
convince the warden because I have a
book to open can you imagine a book
loved on death row you've got people who
are therefore convicted of hanging just
black people this members of the KKK and
he's gotten those guys reading James
Baldwin yes that in the african-american
literature yes you had the grace from
your faith you had your mom talk about
her and Lester Lester Lester with whom
also had lots of grace and
I'm on was my mother and father my
father lost his mind when I was about
four years old and my mom did everything
she could to make sure that we was
brought up right I often say that if I
had one wish in this world I would wish
that every child could have a mother the
way my mother were and I never went
without clothes I never went without
food I never went without ruin wall I
never went without anything that a child
needs but above all of that she gave me
unconditional love and I was blessed to
have a room in the bush and his name was
Lester Bailey and everyone else went
they back home he was there for me he's
here for you today we'll show Lester
anything in the green room and he was
calm and sit and we never did be Causton
my innocent of guilt because he know who
I was and he know the way we was brought
up and so we just always been friends
since the age of four and six and often
people say well you have a true friend
that will come see you and I often tell
people to be honest which he didn't have
a whole lot else to do and so why not
come see me in Smitty I've never missed
a week Lester worked the overnight he
was there I say people need an open
their life I also now say mr. Hinton is
that you're there you watch 54 people
walk by your cell and one woman to go to
the to the death chamber to the electric
chair that you could smell their burning
flesh and you all would cheer you would
scream their names to let them know what
as they were heading to the death we
didn't know whether they had a family or
friend back in the death chamber
watching them and thank you and we
always had this little pact we was
family and we would bang at the balls
they would execute at 12:01
and we would start bringing about 10
minutes tutorial and we were banging -
about 20 minutes after 12 and that was a
signet - the condemned prison no matter
what we are still with you no matter
what we love you and the last thing we
wanted him to hear was the banging on
the boss know somebody cares compassion
you said it has no color where will you
stay we're gonna kill everything else in
the rest of the show we're gonna take a
break we're gonna come back with mr.
Hinton and Oprah we'll be at the table